this episode of fun science is brought
to you by Skillshare let me start by
saying that I'm not going to be talking
about that kind of cute that might
describe the buttocks of that hot guy at
the gym or that new dress you bought
recently which looks great on you by the
way instead we are going to explore that
pure wholesome cuteness that just makes
you want to go in this week's episode oh
yeah now we all know cuteness when we
see it whether that be a cat dog a baby
elephant or a zebra spider wait what do
you mean people don't find zebra spiders
cute just look at its adorable little
eyes but what exactly is cuteness well
to answer that question let's ask some
experts I'm here with an expert in
cuteness young man could you please tell
me what makes you so cute is it your
adorable little face is there a specific
shampoo you use or miss oh it's being so
cute right now and I don't know why any
response at all would be much
appreciated do you what you want to go
down don't you okay that's fine that's
fine whatever however you want to play
this is there anything about your
coloring that makes you particularly
cute you seem to be being bobbed right
now I think that's helping with the
cuteness do you have any comment any
information you can give me what I would
be much appreciated you're not going to
give it up for you
unfortunately we found those particular
experts unwilling to reveal their
secrets so instead we decided to ask a
human professor of cuteness at the
university of coochie-coo
dr. floppy huapi cupcake dr. floppy
puppy cupcake thank you so much for
coming on the show thank you for having
me
so tell me what is cuteness so there are
a number of different physical
attributes that denote cuteness all of
which can be found on the human infant
there's a large head proportionate to
body large eyes that low in the face
what nose and chubby soft skin to name
but a few
Frank but why are those features in
particular considered to be cute
because babies suck no seriously
babies are actually the worst I think
what dr. floppy what we cupcake is
trying to say is that human babies are
an example of offspring that are
completely reliant on their parents
which makes them quite a lot to handle
okay it makes sense then from an
evolutionary standpoint that our brains
would encourage us to want to take care
of our infant children that's continuing
on our species that's why when we see a
baby our natural instinct is to cuddle
protect and nurture it despite the fact
that they are otherwise quite annoying
to take care of now obviously in order
for this to work we need to be able to
recognize a baby when we see one which
we do by taking note of its acute
features however it just so happens that
we can find these same features in other
species too and so we find ourselves
having the same instinct to nurture we
even breed animals with these same
traits this doesn't just apply to other
animals though as if we're able to
recognize these same features in
inanimate objects that we can end up
finding those things cute too the
important thing here is that the only
reason we find these things cute is
because they have features similar to
human infants so if for some reason
babies came out bright green and covered
in spikes then instead of spending our
lunch breaks looking at photos of cute
animals
maybe photos of cacti would be filling
up our Facebook feeds instead oh so
adorable
okay final question what can you tell me
about the dark side of cuteness all
right let me let me show you something
now the contents of this envelope are
too dangerous to share with the public
but I'm gonna allow you to have a bit of
a look enough not yet I'm just gonna
have you look at the images and describe
them to me okay all right let's
oh my gosh so cute okay so fluffy and
little I didn't want to squeeze its
little bones do you want me to do the
next bit for you oh okay what Charlie
just demonstrated is something called
cute aggression and it likely exists to
make us better parents it's similar to
when we laugh so hard that we want to
cry one strong emotion is followed by
the opposite emotion in order to bring
us back to a state of balance which is
particularly important when we're
overwhelmed with cuteness the feelings
of aggression allow us to regain control
leaving us more capable of looking after
our young isn't that right charlie
see you next time being able to enjoy
babies and kittens is awesome obviously
but why not take your passion for the
adorable to the next level and create
your own cuteness the online learning
communities skill share has many classes
just for this like how to draw cute
animals digitally in Adobe Illustrator
or how to 3d model your own cute monster
there's even a class dedicated solely to
showing you how to draw cute watermelon
slices they also have thousands of other
classes for things like photography web
design music production and more plus
the first 500 people who visit the link
in the description will get two months
for free so why not start your learning
now and make some cute things also fun
science is now on patreon so if you want
to support the show directly just go to
patreon.com/scishow fun science and take
a look at some of the perks we have on
offer that's all for now I'll see you
next time bye bye